imagine a world where Humanity has not
only gained the ability to travel and
populate space but has progressed even
further than that
Humanity can now control and navigate
multiple universes
welcome to one of the most advanced
civilizations ever thought of
a type 5 civilization
what is a type 5 civilization
what would it mean for Humanity
and how would we get to this point
hey before we jump into our next
civilization let's talk raid Shadow
Legends it's a PVP PVE game with awesome
graphics and it's my go-to game when I'm
not doing these videos I've seen my
favorite Champion Arbiter or speed Aura
and Revival abilities game changers now
if you're into boss battles well their
Hydro event is a must play two heads to
watch out for the head of suffering
which shares its damage with you and the
head of blight which throws up a poison
Cloud that can de-brail your entire team
if you're not careful this turn-based
MMORPG boasts over 700 unique Champions
it just introduced a metamorph mechanic
allowing Champions to switch forums so a
damage dealing Knight can now turn into
an angel of healing so cool right log in
seven times before October 23rd to snag
a free legendary champion soon Wukong
and newbies downloading by October 7th
can use the code JT skin for a top tier
epic Champion stag Knight as well as his
skin designed by JonTron himself so what
are you waiting for click the link or
scan the QR code for a free starter pack
with Epic Loot see you on the
battlefield
okay so before we get to our epic type 5
civilization we first need to start at
zero
this is unfortunately where Earth is
right now
type zero civilization is one that's
reliant on things like fossil fuels and
still struggling with issues like
climate change yeah we've sent people to
the moon and Rovers to Mars but we're
far from Interstellar travel and
although we have lots of technological
advancements we're still vulnerable to
things like natural disasters and
pandemics
[Music]
so although Earth is highly advanced in
many ways we still have a long way to go
before we reach a type one or two or
five civilization
how do we get there
well before we get to that what are
these civilizations anyway and who came
up with them
it's known as the kardashev scale
developed by Nikolai kardashev in 1964
the scale categorizes a civilization
according to its technological
capabilities and energy consumption
originally the scale only involved type
1 2 and 3 civilizations but it's since
been expanded to include Type 4 and 5.
now while civilizations four and five
are mostly speculative and theoretical
civilizations one through three could
happen someday
so how could humans become a type 5
civilization
not so fast first we need to get to a
type one
there's no way a civilization can jump
from a zero all the way to five
so let's get started
type 1 civilization
a type 1 civilization would be a massive
improvement from where we are now on
Earth as a type one we could harness all
the energy available to us on the planet
imagine being able to harness the power
of the oceans and the Sun
things like hurricanes and earthquakes
would become minor inconveniences and
all our energy would be renewable
now to get to this point the main thing
we need to focus on would be energy
transition shifting from non-renewable
to renewable energy sources would be the
key priority and it would need to be
done at a global scale
think entire deserts filled with solar
panels wind turbines covering the clouds
and ocean thermal energy conversion
plants
other scientific advancements would also
be essential things like Quantum
Computing and advanced AI would be key
parts of helping us transition into this
new civilization
but it's not just about the technology
we'd also need some sort of global
governance to help unify the world to
tackle these massive challenges experts
think that this might happen in the next
Century or two
but we don't have time to wait that long
so let's fast forward and move on to the
next type of civilization we got four
more to go
type 2 civilization
this would be a massive leap on all
fronts of energy and technological
advancement being a type 2 would mean
that we'd be able to build extreme
megastructures like this Dyson Sphere
this would allow us to harness the power
of the Sun and with that our energy
capability would be virtually Limitless
we could innovate our way to incredible
technological Heights instead of being
Tethered to Earth we now have the power
to travel to new planets and start
populating them
Mars Venus and other planets in our
solar system would become our new homes
and overall the solar system would
become a Utopia with humans having this
much power we'd move Beyond things like
scarcity war and inequality
a unified Galactic government would span
across our star system
but it would take some hard work
becoming a type 2 civilization would
require all of Humanity's effort and
span multiple Generations
type 3 civilization
you think harnessing the power of our
Earth and Sun is epic how about an
entire galaxy
well that's what you can expect when
transitioning to a Type 3 civilization
things like black holes billions of
stars and other celestial bodies would
all be at Humanity's disposal to harness
and use
this could allow for Wormhole travel you
can instantly travel to distant points
in the galaxy
and if that wasn't enough we'd also have
the ability to terraform different
planets however we please
I kind of want to ski on Venus
Type 4 civilization
okay now is where things get really
crazy a Type 4 civilization is beginning
to reach a point beyond our current
understanding of the universe and
physics so naturally there would be some
weird aspects to this upgraded version
of humanity
being able to terraform planets and
control celestial bodies was so last
Civilization now we reshape destroy or
create entire worlds
we would have unlimited power having
mastered the resources of the entire
universe
things like artificial intelligence
would become so Advanced by this point
that they'd become part of the structure
of the universe
with that we'd be able to control
virtually every aspect of
we could manipulate time and create
different timelines
create new life forms and different
kinds of matter
and on top of all that in a Type 4
civilization we'd be able to transcend
biological limitations and achieve a
form of immortality
pretty crazy right
well we're not even done yet
type 5 civilization
similar to a Type 4 civilization a type
5 civilization would be dealing with
problems and obstacles that we can't
even comprehend
but what we do know is that this
civilization would be able to do
virtually anything
the people or whatever they would evolve
to at this point would essentially
become gods
they could instantly create new
universes with specific conditions that
they could use to experiment with new
life
they could effectively create their own
simulations ones that are even more
complex than the world we live in today
and the key difference would be that a
type 5 civilization would have access to
and control of multiple universes yeah
instead of being limited to just one
puny Universe we would now become a
multiversal civilization this means
everything we could do in one Universe
our control of energy and our access to
resources would now be multiplied across
the entire Multiverse
now what happens after that is almost
incomprehensible
a type 6 or 7 civilization May mean that
Humanity merges with the fabric of
reality itself
we might go beyond our physical reality
and who knows what happens after that
but no doubt it'd be pretty crazy
now you know what might be even crazier
if we are living in a simulation right
now
but that sounds like a story
for another
what if
[Music]